Every year in the fall, in countries all over the world, signs go up advertising a lottery, a lottery whose winners move to the United States, get a green card, and become Americans. And though it might sound crazy to you, and impossible--
每年秋天，世界各地的国家都会贴出告示，宣传一种抽奖活动，中奖者可以移居美国，获得绿卡并成为美国人。对你来说，这听起来可能很疯狂，甚至是不可能的——
Everybody know, I mean everybody. This sign is all over on the street, all over, in the stores, in the shops. Everywhere you pass, you see it.
人人都知道，我是说所有人。这个招牌到处都是，街上、商店里、店铺里，到处都是。无论你经过哪里，都能看到它。
That's Reuben Henry who runs an internet cafe in Liberia. The lottery application is online, so internet cafes are where lots of people apply. They're the ones who put up the signs advertising it. This year, Reuben says, over 1,000 people put in applications at his place. He doesn't know any Liberian who hasn't heard of it.
那是鲁本·亨利，他在利比里亚经营一家网吧。抽奖申请是在网上进行的，所以网吧成了很多人申请的地方。正是他们贴出了宣传这种抽奖的招牌。鲁本说，今年在他那里提交申请的人超过了1000个。他不认识任何没听说过这件事的利比里亚人。
Not anyone at all, except the baby who was born today.
一个都没有，除了今天刚出生的婴儿。
If you haven't heard of this lottery, it's probably because you already live here and you don't need it. It's not a scam. It's a real thing run by the United States government every year called the Diversity Visa lottery, or the DV lottery for short. The idea is to get a more varied group of immigrants from a diversity of countries into our country. In any given year, between 8 and 15 million people apply with over 100,000 winners.
如果你没听说过这种抽奖，那可能是因为你已经住在这里了，不需要它。这不是骗局，而是美国政府每年举办的真实活动，叫多元化移民签证抽奖，简称DV抽奖。它的理念是让来自不同国家的更多元化的移民群体进入我国。每年都有800万到1500万人申请，中奖者超过10万人。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语语音]
Some of them are very quiet and they start to cry.
他们中的一些人非常安静，开始流泪。
I spoke to this man, Mr. Bala, with an interpreter. He owns a cyber cafe in Sri Lanka. He says he gets about 800 applicants a year at his place, and about 20 winners.
我通过翻译与巴拉先生交谈。他在斯里兰卡拥有一家网吧。他说他那里每年约有800名申请者，大约有20人中奖。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语语音]
Some, according to him, jump up and down and they just scream, and so excited. While yet the rest will be, you know, banging on the walls and just screaming their head off and hugging Mr. Bala or anybody who's nearby that they were so happy that they were selected.
据他说，有些人又蹦又跳，尖叫不已，非常兴奋。而其他人则会用力拍打墙壁，疯狂尖叫，拥抱巴拉先生或任何身边的人，因为他们对自己被选中感到无比高兴。
The way it works, people apply online in October, the winners are randomly chosen, and the results are posted in May. At a cyber cafe in the Congo, when Eric Muamba told one woman, "God's blessed you, you've won," she kissed him.
运作方式是这样的：人们在十月份在线申请，获胜者被随机抽取，结果在五月份公布。在刚果的一家网吧，当埃里克·穆安巴告诉一位女士“上帝保佑你，你中奖了”时，她亲吻了他。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语语音]
And I was so embarrassed that-- since the husband was there, I also ran to the husband and hugged the husband, you know, just to cool the tension, because I did not want her husband to think-- I mean, to have some ideas.
当时我很尴尬，因为她的丈夫也在场，所以我跑到她丈夫那里拥抱了他，你知道，只是为了缓解紧张气氛，因为我不希望她丈夫产生其他想法。
In Kenya, Michael Kadi Abu Niwa had the very first winner in his cybercafe two years ago. Basically he just noticed a commotion over at the computers.
在肯尼亚，迈克尔·卡迪·阿布·尼瓦两年前在他的网吧里迎来了第一位获胜者。他只是注意到电脑那边一阵骚动。
Shouting, laughing, trying to shake him. And the guys were around there, "you won it! You won it!"
大喊大叫，欢笑，试图摇晃他。周围的人都在喊：“你中了！你中了！”
Mike told the guy, "you're now an American."
迈克告诉那个人：“你现在是美国人了。”
Hey, you are now an American. You are now an American. You're going to a land of opportunities, and remember us when you're there. When you leave this country, don't forget about us. That's what I told him.
嘿，你现在是美国人了。你现在是美国人了。你要去一个充满机会的土地，记得在那边关照我们。当你离开这个国家时，别忘了我们。我就是这么告诉他的。
The guy who won that day was not a Kenyan. He was a Somali refugee named Abdi, Abdi Nor. He remembers the moment this way. He sat down at the computer.
那天中奖的人不是肯尼亚人，而是一位名叫阿卜迪·诺尔的索马里难民。他这样回忆当时的情景。他在电脑前坐了下来。
I put my confirmation number. I put my date of birth, and then clicked submit. There was a few seconds of silence, then "you have been randomly selected."
我输入了我的确认号码。我输入了出生日期，然后点击提交。沉默了几秒钟，接着屏幕上显示“您已被随机选中”。
Everybody went nuts, lifted him up in the air in his chair. But Abdi didn't believe it. He asked his friends to put him down and started entering his information into the computer again, and again.
所有人都疯了，连人带椅子把他举到空中。但阿卜迪不相信。他让朋友们把他放下来，开始一次又一次地在电脑上输入信息。
It's the same answer, the same response. I put in-- same response. I realized I won. I walked out with these friends all shouting behind me, in front of me, you know, holding my hands, shaking me. My heart was bumping. I was not holding myself together.
还是同样的答案，同样的回复。我输入了——还是同样的回复。我意识到我真的中奖了。我和那些朋友们走出来，他们在我身后和前方尖叫，抓住我的手，摇晃着我。我的心跳个不停。我简直无法控制自己。
Moving to America seemed like a done deal. But he didn't know the half of it. Abdi is who our show's about today, and winning the lottery was an especially big deal for Abdi because, really more than anybody he knew, Abdi had been obsessed with America since he was little. As a kid growing up in Mogadishu, Somalia, he would go to the movies which, in Mogadishu just meant a TV perched on a table in a shack.
移居美国似乎已成定局。但他还不知道这只是冰山一角。阿卜迪就是我们今天节目的主角，中奖对阿卜迪来说尤其重大，因为他从小就对美国极其着迷，比他认识的任何人都更甚。作为一个在索马里摩加迪沙长大的孩子，他会去看电影，在摩加迪沙，这仅仅意味着在棚屋的桌子上放着一台电视机。
And he would bring a pen and paper to watch American films so he could write down any words he didn't know and learn the language better. He became known to people as the guy who could translate the movie for you. Stuff would happened on screen and everybody would turn to Abdi, who would shout out, "he says he's about to kill that guy."
他会带着纸笔去看美国电影，这样他就可以记下所有不认识的单词，更好地学习语言。他成了人们口中那个能为你翻译电影的人。屏幕上发生什么事，大家都转向阿卜迪，他会喊道：“他说他要杀掉那个人。”
He pronounces English like an American. That's why his accent is so amazing when you hear him, which led to his nickname, that all his friends called him.
他的英语发音像美国人一样。这就是为什么当你听到他说话时，他的口音如此惊人，这也导致了他所有的朋友都称呼他的那个绰号。
Abdi the American. That's my name. That's my nickname.
“阿卜迪美国人”。那是我的名字，那是我的绰号。
And as he got older, he devoted himself to the goal of getting to America, not only studying English, but also teaching it. He did some radio stories in English. And you can totally understand why he'd want to leave his country, right?
随着年龄增长，他全身心投入到去美国的目标中，不仅学习英语，还教授英语。他用英语做过一些广播报道。你可以完全理解他为什么要离开自己的国家，对吧？
He grew up in Somalia. For years there was no functioning government. There was rival warlords and militias and just anarchy, dangerous and violent. And there were bombings and attacks from the terrorist group al-Shabaab, which is affiliated with al-Qaeda. Abdi says for him, or really for any man in his 20s in Somalia, it's hard to stay out of the fight. You can't just be neutral and go about your life.
他在索马里长大。多年来，那里没有正常的政府。那里有敌对的军阀和民兵，只有无政府状态，危险而暴力。还有恐怖组织“青年党”发动的爆炸袭击，该组织与基地组织有关联。阿卜迪说，对他来说，或者对任何20多岁的索马里男人来说，很难远离战斗。你无法保持中立并过自己的生活。
He tells stories of al-Shabaab members threatening him to join them, or else. At one checkpoint on the way to his mom's they told him, basically, next time you come through here, you'd better be one of us. So it was that or join the government forces who were fighting al-Shabaab, or he could flee the country.
他讲述了“青年党”成员威胁他加入他们的故事，否则就没命。在去他妈妈路上的一个检查站，他们基本上告诉他，下次你再经过这里时，最好是我们的一员。所以要么加入他们，要么加入与“青年党”作战的政府军，或者他只能逃离这个国家。
You know those boats full of people who are trying to cross the Mediterranean to get to Europe, and sometimes they sink, and hundreds of people drown? Abdi knows people who have gone on those boats, and on boats like them, to escape to Yemen.
你知道那些试图穿越地中海去欧洲的船只，挤满了人，有时它们会沉没，数百人淹死吗？阿卜迪认识一些坐过那些船，或者类似船只逃往也门的人。
Yes. I've lost three very good friends. And one of these friends had his child, less than a year old, with his wife. He knew how to swim, but he could not swim because his child was-- you know, he was trying to save his child and his wife. And then they were caught up in the sea and sharks.
是的。我失去了三个非常好的朋友。其中一个朋友带着他不到一岁的孩子和妻子一起。他会游泳，但他没法游，因为他当时正试图救他的孩子和妻子。然后他们被卷入海中，成了鲨鱼的猎物。
They were not the only ones who died there. 75 other Somalis were killed in that journey. And that has changed nothing about our decision. That doesn't scare us a lot. We know death is there.
不仅仅是他们死在那里。另有75名索马里人在那次旅程中丧生。但这并没有改变我们的决定。这并不能吓倒我们。我们知道死亡就在那里。
Several times, Abdi planned to take one of those boats, but he had trouble getting the money together, and eventually his mom talked him out of it. So instead, he escaped across the border to Kenya. Somalia and Kenya are next to each other. Abdi moved to Nairobi, enrolled in a university, tried twice for a student visa to America, was denied both times. And if he hadn't gotten lucky that day in the cybercafe, he said he would have been looking again and getting on a boat.
阿卜迪曾多次计划乘坐那些船，但他很难筹到钱，最终他妈妈劝阻了他。所以相反，他穿过边境逃到了肯尼亚。索马里和肯尼亚紧邻。阿卜迪搬到了内罗毕，注册了一所大学，两次尝试申请美国学生签证，都被拒绝了。他说，如果那天在网吧没有好运，他本来会再次考虑并登上那些船。
Yeah. If I had not won this green card lottery, that was one of my options. I was not afraid to do that. I'm looking for a life. And to get to that, I'll keep trying to the death.
是的。如果我没有赢得这次绿卡抽奖，那是我的选择之一。我不害怕这样做。我在寻找生活。为了达到那个目标，我愿意尝试到死。
The thing about the lottery though, what Abdi learned, is that it does not guarantee you a life in America. In fact, it's just the first step. After you win you have to wait more than a year, then you show up at an American embassy for an interview, and you have to gather all kinds of paperwork to bring with you, medical documents and school transcripts and a criminal background check. Everything has to be perfect. Every "i" dotted. The tiniest mistake means that you can be denied for good.
但关于抽奖，阿卜迪学到的一点是，它并不能保证你在美国的生活。事实上，这只是第一步。中奖后，你必须等待一年多，然后去美国大使馆面试。你必须收集各种文件带去，包括医疗记录、学校成绩单和无犯罪记录证明。一切都必须完美无缺。每一个“i”都要点上。最小的错误都意味着你可能被永久拒绝。
In fact, most years, over half the people who win the lottery never get their visas. They don't make it to America. And right away, after winning the lottery, Abdi got a bad break. The police in Nairobi, Kenya, where he lived, started raiding houses, looking around up all the Somalis like him and kick them out of the country. We have a very unusual day-by-day record of what happened to Abdi because a BBC reporter named Leo Hornak wanted to document this process and started calling Abdi every night. This is one of their very first recordings.
事实上，大多数年份，超过一半的中奖者从未拿到签证。他们没能去成美国。而且在赢得抽奖后，阿卜迪马上就遭遇了挫折。他居住的肯尼亚内罗毕警方开始突袭住宅，搜捕像他一样的索马里人并将他们驱逐出境。我们有一份关于阿卜迪遭遇的非常罕见的日常记录，因为一位名叫利奥·霍纳克的BBC记者想记录这个过程，并开始每晚给阿卜迪打电话。这是他们最早的录音之一。
[DIALING]
[拨号声]
Hey, Abdi, can you hear me?
嘿，阿卜迪，能听到我说话吗？
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I can hear you.
听得到，听得到。
Are you safe right now, for the moment?
你现在安全吗，暂时？
Yeah. I'm safe.
是的，我安全。
You sent me an email that had me really worried today. Tell me what happened.
你今天发给我的邮件让我非常担心。告诉我发生了什么。
Yeah, it was crazy. I was actually chatting with some of the people in our apartment when these guys-- we don't call them the police. We called them the guys. Out of nowhere they appeared there at the gate, and they asked us all to raise our hands up. And [SIGH] you know, we-- we were thinking, like, OK. This is the end of it. We're going to go there tonight.
是的，太疯狂了。我当时正在和公寓里的一些人聊天，这时这些家伙——我们不叫他们警察，我们叫他们“那些人”。他们凭空出现在门口，要求我们所有人举起手来。然后 [叹气] 你知道，我们都在想，好吧，我们要完蛋了，今晚就要被抓走了。
By "there," he means a place called Kasarani, a giant soccer stadium that Kenyan authorities and police were using as a makeshift jail to hold hundreds of refugees.
他说的“那里”是指一个叫卡萨拉尼的地方，这是一个巨大的足球场，肯尼亚当局和警察把它当作临时监狱，关押了数百名难民。
Like, oh my God. The next few, couple of nights you're going to be spending there in the concentration camp, and then they take you to Mogadishu. And, OK, you're going to miss your lottery. All those things were going through my mind.
就像，天哪。接下来的几个晚上要在那个集中营里度过，然后他们把你带回摩加迪沙。好吧，你要错过你的抽奖了。所有这些念头都在我脑海中闪过。
This call happened on April 17th, 2014. Abdi had 96 days to go before his interview at the US embassy, which would be scheduled for July 22nd. Leo started calling him every day. He was worried for him. Like I say, over half the people who win the lottery never make it to the United States. Would Abdi succeed?
这通电话发生在2014年4月17日。距离他在美国大使馆的面试还有96天，面试定于7月22日。利奥开始每天给他打电话。他为他感到担心。就像我说的，超过一半的中奖者从未去成美国。阿卜迪能成功吗？
Over the next three months he faced a horrifying obstacle course. It's just like one seemingly impossible task after another. At several points he's afraid for his life. Today we bring you the story of one of the many people around the world who are desperately trying to make it to America, to become one of us. Will Abdi do it? Stay with us.
在接下来的三个月里，他经历了一场恐怖的障碍赛。就像一个看似不可能的任务接着另一个。有好几次他都担心自己的生命安全。今天，我们为您带来世界各地许多拼命想去美国、想成为我们一员的人中的一个故事。阿卜迪能做到吗？请留下来。
OK, so you remember where we are. Abdi is about to be taken into custody by the police. Here's Leo Hornak.
好吧，你还记得我们现在的处境。阿卜迪即将被警方拘留。这是利奥·霍纳克。
So here's why the police were raiding Abdi's neighborhood in Nairobi. Al-Shabaab was the very group Abdi moved to Kenya to escape, have been ramping up terrorist attacks inside Kenya. You may remember one of the biggest ones.
所以，这就是为什么警察要突袭阿卜迪所在的内罗毕社区的原因。“青年党”正是阿卜迪为了逃避而搬到肯尼亚的那个组织，他们一直在肯尼亚境内加强恐怖袭击。你可能记得其中最大的一次。
The hostage crisis in the upscale Westgate Mall is ongoing. The chaotic scene now a tense standoff. ABC's--
高档西门购物中心的劫持人质危机仍在继续。混乱的现场现在处于紧张的对峙状态。美国广播公司的——
In September 2013, al-Shabaab gunmen trapped hundreds of people in a mall for days, and killed 67. The way the Kenyan government responded to these terrorist attacks was the way governments often do in these situations, with a huge crackdown on the community they hold responsible. Al-Shabaab's from Somalia, so they go after Somali refugees living in Kenya.
2013年9月，“青年党”枪手将数百人困在商场里数天，并杀害了67人。肯尼亚政府应对这些恐怖袭击的方式，往往是政府在这种情况下惯用的做法，即对他们认为负责的群体进行大规模镇压。“青年党”来自索马里，所以他们针对生活在肯尼亚的索马里难民。
Government's trying to clear them out of Kenya's cities and move them to camps in the country or deport them back to Somalia. And in Nairobi the neighborhood they target is Abdi's neighborhood. It's called Eastleigh. It's a dense neighborhood where many poor Somalis live, and where there is some al-Shabaab support. Eastleigh's been there for decades. It's known as Little Mogadishu. Abdi lives there with his older brother Hassan in a small room with one bed and a single bathroom for the whole building.
政府试图将他们从肯尼亚的城市清理出去，转移到该国的营地或将他们遣返回索马里。在内罗毕，他们瞄准的社区就是阿卜迪的社区，叫东利。这是一个人口稠密的社区，许多贫穷的索马里人住在这里，而且那里有一些“青年党”的支持者。东利存在了几十年，被称为“小摩加迪沙”。阿卜迪和他的哥哥哈桑住在那里，住在一个带一张床和整个楼共用一个卫生间的小房间里。
So back to that phone call on April 17th. The police show up and grab Abdi by the shirt.
回到4月17日的那通电话。警察出现并抓住阿卜迪的领口。
They just get your collar and hold it so tight. And they tell you, come with me and just get into the truck. That's what they said to all of us.
他们只是抓住你的衣领，勒得紧紧的。他们告诉你，跟我走，上卡车。他们对我们所有人都这么说。
It's 96 days until Abdi's interview, and Abdi's worried they're going to throw him and his brother into a truck and take them into detention before he can ever get his papers together and leave for America.
距离阿卜迪面试还有96天，阿卜迪担心他们会把他和哥哥扔进卡车，带到拘留所，这样他就永远没法整理好文件离开去美国了。
They threaten you and they try to forcibly take you to the tracks. We were not going with them. We were saying, OK, let's negotiate. I'm not going anywhere. I have legitimate documents. And they were telling us, OK, bring out all your documents. What do you have?
他们威胁你，试图强行把你带到卡车上。我们没有跟他们走。我们在说，好吧，让我们协商。我哪儿也不去。我有合法证件。他们对我们说，好吧，把你们所有的证件拿出来。你们有什么？
Abdi pulls out his refugee ID. Officially, that should protect Abdi. It's from the United Nations. Unofficially--
阿卜迪掏出他的难民证。按照官方规定，那应该保护阿卜迪。它是联合国的证件。但非官方地——
He didn't even try to give it single glance, because he knows the shape. He knows the frame of it. And he says-- he threw it into my face and he says, "you're a refugee? What are you doing here?" And they were like, "Come on, give us whatever you have." That's what one of them said.
他甚至看都没看一眼，因为他知道那个样子，知道那个边框。他把它扔在我的脸上说：“你是难民？你在这里干什么？”他们说：“快，把你们有的东西都交出来。”他们中的一个就是这么说的。
So that's when the real business starts.
于是真正的生意开始了。
Yeah, when the real business starts.
是的，真正的生意开始了。
AKA, the bribes. Abdi, his brother, and the neighbors start pooling their cash.
也就是行贿。阿卜迪、他的哥哥和邻居们开始凑钱。
In total, I think we gave them more than 80 US dollars. And I had to beg them. Please, I have nothing. That's all I have in life. Nothing. I have nothing. This is all I have. Please, you have to take it.
总共，我想我们给了他们超过80美元。我不得不求他们。拜托，我什么都没有。这是我生命中所有的积蓄了。什么都没有。我一无所有。这是我仅有的钱。求你了，你一定要收下。
And how much does 80 US dollars buy you in Eastleigh.
80美元在东利能买到什么？
It gives you the best food. It's better jeans, better shirts, jacket, all that stuff. It's a lot of money. It's, indeed, a lot of money.
它能买到最好的食物。更好的牛仔裤、更好的衬衫、夹克，所有这些东西。这是一大笔钱。确实，这是一大笔钱。
And, Abdi, what happens next? I mean, there's no solution, right, to this? This could happen again tomorrow.
那么，阿卜迪，接下来会发生什么？我的意思是，没有解决办法，对吧？这种情况明天可能还会发生。
Not even tomorrow. It can happen right now. It can happen to tonight. It can happen in the next few minutes. It can happen in the next few hours.
甚至不只是明天。它现在就可能发生。今晚就可能发生。接下来几分钟内就可能发生。接下来几个小时内就可能发生。
Talking to Abdi every day, what I realized was how relentless it is. Every night's another excuse for a crackdown, and the Somalis are sitting ducks, trapped in this one neighborhood.
每天和阿卜迪交谈，我意识到这是多么无情。每一晚都是镇压的借口，而索马里人成了瓮中之鳖，被困在这个社区里。
Most people are indoors today. They're not going to anywhere. They're not coming out of their houses.
今天大多数人都待在室内。他们哪儿也不去。他们不出门。
April 25th, 88 days to Abdi's interview, and counting. It's a Friday, which normally would be a busy day in Eastleigh because it's a Muslim holy day. People take off from work, go shopping, go out to eat, to meet at the mosque for prayers. But not today. Abdi says last week the police showed up at a nearby mosque, grabbed people as they left prayers, and drove them away in trucks.
4月25日，距离阿卜迪面试还有88天，倒计时中。今天是星期五，按理说东利应该非常繁忙，因为这是穆斯林圣日。人们休息、购物、外出就餐、去清真寺祈祷。但今天没有。阿卜迪说上周警察出现在附近的清真寺，抓住离开祈祷的人，把他们用车拉走了。
We're getting additional threats from the police saying that they will intensify the operations and that they will take more people.
我们收到警察的进一步威胁，称他们将加强行动，带走更多人。
So, Abdi, what do you think you're going to do today? Will you visit a mosque?
那么，阿卜迪，你觉得你今天打算做什么？你会去清真寺吗？
No, I will not. I never missed a prayer on Friday, but this one-- but this one. Never missed. But you never know.
不，我不会。我从未错过周五的祈祷，但这一次——这一次。从未错过。但你永远不知道会发生什么。
Soon, Abdi stops leaving his apartment for anything. He and his brother, Hassan, essentially go into hiding, lockdown in their building. They stop going to school. As the days go by, food begins to run short. Abdi and Hassan pool their supplies with another Somali family on the ground floor of their building, two women, one a single mother with two small boys. But it's not much.
很快，阿卜迪停止了外出。他和哥哥哈桑基本上躲了起来，锁在公寓里。他们不再上学。随着日子一天天过去，食物开始短缺。阿卜迪和哈桑与楼下一户索马里家庭分享物资，那家有两个女人，其中一个是带着两个小男孩的单亲母亲。但也没多少。
Soon they're down to just tea and sugar, and a loaf of bread they're able to get each day from a Kenyan guy who delivers it on his bike. That's what they were living on. Tea and bread.
很快他们只剩下茶和糖，以及每天从一个骑自行车送货的肯尼亚人那里买来的一条面包。他们就是靠这个生存的。茶和面包。
Our eyes are turning red and the energy's running out. We're looking, like, pretty skinny.
我们的眼睛变红了，能量在耗尽。我们看起来，呃，很瘦。
Abdi and Hassan are paying for the tea and bread with money they get from overseas. Years ago Abdi did some reports for an American public radio show called The Story , and a listener reached out wanting to help. She sends them money, not too different from lots of Somali refugees who have family members abroad supporting them. But, obviously, that kind of help only goes so far.
阿卜迪和哈桑用从海外得到的钱买茶和面包。几年前，阿卜迪为一家美国公共广播节目《The Story》做过一些报道，一位听众伸出援手想要帮助他。她寄钱给他们，这与许多有海外亲属资助的索马里难民没什么不同。但显然，这种帮助杯水车薪。
It's challenging because, you know, you can't even shut your eyes at night and sleep soundly.
这很艰难，你知道，你晚上甚至无法闭眼睡个安稳觉。
This is Abdi's older brother, Hassan. He tells me they aren't sleeping. He and Abdi sound the same, by the way. Apparently even their father can't tell them apart on the phone.
这是阿卜迪的哥哥哈桑。他告诉我他们睡不着。顺便说一下，他和阿卜迪听起来一模一样。显然连他们父亲在电话里都分不清他们。
Any minute you expect someone breaking into your house or grabbing you. It's like sleeping with your pants on, you know? You are always ready. You don't know what's happening, you know?
随时你都担心有人闯进你的房子或抓走你。这就像穿着裤子睡觉，你知道吗？你时刻准备着。你不知道发生了什么，你知道吗？
Yeah. Wow.
是的。哇。
Feeling at home is like you relax, you watch a movie, something like-- that never happens. If you hear another sound outside or some other knocking or, you know, a small kind of sound-- what was it? What's happening? Are they coming? We are not criminals, just refugees. And I never thought being a refugee will make you sound like criminal.
在家本应是放松、看电影，这种感觉——这永远不会发生。如果你听到外面有声音或者敲门声或者，你知道，一点点声音——那是什么？发生了什么？他们来了吗？我们不是罪犯，只是难民。我从未想过作为难民会让你听起来像罪犯。
The kind of police abuses Abdi told me about are well-documented by human rights groups and journalists-- arbitrary arrest, extortion, beatings, forcible deportation, family members separated. It's illegal under international law to send refugees back to a country where their lives could be in danger. The spokesman for Kenya's Ministry of Interior, which oversaw the police raids in Eastleigh, told me they were justified to make the city safe from al-Shabaab. But he confirmed that the kind of police corruption Abdi told me about has been a problem for a long time in Kenya. That is a fact, he said. We're not denying that.
阿卜迪告诉我的那种警察滥用权力的情况，人权组织和记者都有充分记录——任意拘留、敲诈勒索、殴打、强行驱逐、妻离子散。根据国际法，将难民遣返回生命可能受到威胁的国家是非法的。肯尼亚内政部（负责监督东利警察突袭）的发言人告诉我，他们为了使城市免受“青年党”的伤害而采取行动是合理的。但他承认，阿卜迪告诉我的那种警察腐败在肯尼亚确实是一个长期存在的问题。他说，这是一个事实。我们并不否认。
Abdi and Hassan tell me Eastleigh's come up with a warning system. The first person to spot the police from his window fires a group text to his friends to say, they're coming your way, so you've got time to hide. Then you pass the message on to your friends, and so on. You can tell a raid's started, Hassan says, when you hear all the phones going off.
阿卜迪和哈桑告诉我，东利已经建立了一套预警系统。第一个从窗户发现警察的人会发群短信给朋友，说他们正朝你的方向来，所以你有时间躲藏。然后你把消息传给你的朋友，依此类推。哈桑说，当听到所有的手机响起来时，你就知道突袭开始了。
With just three months left until his interview, Abdi still needs to get all the documents required by the US embassy, documents from the police, his school, his doctors. But he can't do any of that because he can't even leave his building. The clock's ticking.
距离面试仅剩三个月，阿卜迪仍然需要获得美国大使馆要求的所有文件，来自警察、学校、医生的文件。但他什么也做不了，因为他甚至无法离开公寓楼。时间在流逝。
This is a long dream. My hopes were high to get this thing. But now, today, I'm in trouble, you know?
这是一个长期的梦想。我曾对获得这个机会抱有很大希望。但现在，今天，我有麻烦了，你知道吗？
Right.
对。
It's not the Americans who are, you know, putting my visa into trouble, it's the Kenyans, the Kenyan police. And I'm supposed to have my interview here in July. My heart's broke, you know? My feelings are very, very bad. I'm feeling like, OK, you're not going to make it.
不是美国人在给我的签证制造麻烦，而是肯尼亚人，肯尼亚警察。我本应在七月在这里面试。我的心碎了，你知道吗？我的感受非常、非常糟糕。我觉得，好吧，你不会成功了。
April 28th, t-minus 85 days until his interview. Instead of hiding from the police, people are now surrendering. From his window Abdi sees entire families sitting on the sidewalk with their belongings.
4月28日，距离他的面试还有85天。人们不再躲避警察，而是投降了。从窗户看去，阿卜迪看到整个家庭坐在人行道上，带着他们的行李。
Hundreds of families are on the move back to Somalia, are ready to show themselves to the police and say, all right, I'm done.
成百上千的家庭正准备搬回索马里，准备向警察自首，说，好吧，我受够了。
I'm done. They don't have any more money to pay off the police. And rather than end up at the football stadium, they'll just go back to Somalia. Even the family on the ground floor, the two women with the young boys, are packing up.
我受够了。他们没有更多的钱贿赂警察。与其最后被关进足球场，他们宁愿回到索马里。连楼下那家带着小男孩的两个女人也在打包。
Which really broke the heart of my brother and I because that means we're going to be alone here.
这让我的兄弟和我心碎，因为这意味着我们要在这里孤军奋战了。
Did you have any conversations with them about their plans, what they're afraid of? Can you tell me about any conversation you had with any member of that family?
你和她们讨论过她们的计划吗？她们害怕什么？能告诉我你和那个家庭成员的任何对话吗？
What they are telling me, Abdi, what are you doing here? Come on, move. You're dreaming about America. That doesn't exist. This is a dream. Come on, boy. You are wrong. That's what they're me, Leo. At some point I'm thinking, like, would it be OK to go with them? This is totally no life.
她们告诉我的话是，阿卜迪，你在这里干什么？快走。你在梦想美国。那不存在。这是一个梦。快走，孩子。你错了。她们就是这么对我说的，利奥。在某个时刻，我在想，和她们一起走会更好吗？这根本不是生活。
I guess it can't be safe for two unaccompanied women with small children to be traveling by car from Nairobi to Somalia. It can't be safe, right?
我想，两个没有陪同的女性带着幼小的孩子开车从内罗毕前往索马里是不安全的。这肯定不安全，对吧？
They're expecting everything. They're expecting an extortion of property, they are expecting a rape. Because there are gangs on the road that can rape women, and the gangs know that there are Somalis on the move. So they're somewhere on the road where there's no police in sight, so they can come and jump into buses, rape women, take their money.
她们预料到了所有情况。她们预料到财产被勒索，预料到被强奸。因为路上有可以强奸女性的帮派，帮派知道路上有索马里人在移动。所以她们在路上的某个地方，那里没有警察，所以他们可以过来跳上巴士，强奸妇女，拿走她们的钱。
And, you know, the other thing that these families are fearing when they reach a border between Kenya and Somalia, another chapter of danger begins because it's al-Shabaab that are lurking around the border. And when you fall into the hands of al-Shabaab, you disappear forever.
而且，你知道，当这些家庭到达肯尼亚和索马里边境时，另一章危险就开始了，因为“青年党”潜伏在边境附近。当你落入“青年党”手中，你就永远消失了。
The other thing that I was also discussing with them about this seven-year-old and a five-year-old kid is because these are the age that the al-Shabaab-- they really want to program the kids and teach them, you know, whatever ideologies they believe. And so, yeah. The lady looked like she was so much worried for her kids than for herself. Knowing this, these two ladies and the kids must go.
我和她们讨论的另一件事是关于那个七岁和五岁的孩子，因为这正是“青年党”想要给孩子洗脑，教导他们所谓的意识形态的年龄。所以，是的。那位女士看起来为她的孩子担心多过为她自己。知道这些，这两个女士和孩子必须离开。
Wow.
哇。
It's really. So you have got a lot of things to think about. A lot of things to worry about.
确实。所以你有很多事情要考虑。有很多事情要担心。
One night, on the phone, Abdi asked me if I'm familiar with the migration of the wildebeest. Abdi wants to be clear. He doesn't know about this because he's African. He's a city kid. He's just seen it on Discovery Channel clips, like everyone else. Anyway, each year thousands and thousands of wildebeest trek to a river that they have to cross in order to graze on the other side. The river's infested with crocodiles, and not every wildebeest makes it, but they all have to try.
一天晚上，在电话里，阿卜迪问我是否了解角马的迁徙。阿卜迪想澄清一下。他不是因为他是非洲人才知道这个的。他是个城市孩子。他只是像其他人一样在探索频道的片段里看到的。总之，每年成千上万的角马为了到另一边吃草必须跨越一条河流。河里到处是鳄鱼，并不是每头角马都能过去，但它们都必须尝试。
Abdi says he knows how they feel. Somalis are prey, he says. They're being hunted.
阿卜迪说他知道它们的感觉。他说，索马里人是猎物。他们正在被捕猎。
Each evening, when I phoned Abdi, I was always concerned that one night no one would answer, that he would have finally taken the advice of his neighbors or been hauled off to the holding pens in Kasarani. When he did pick up, often he wanted to talk about things that weren't related to the Kenyan police or al-Shabaab. We talked about his favorite movies, Rambo , that movie The Rock with Nicolas Cage, anything Schwarzenegger. We talked about his friends in the good old days in Eastleigh, when he could sit in a cafe and sip tea with camel milk.
每天晚上，当我给阿卜迪打电话时，我总是担心有一天没人会接，他可能最终听从了邻居的建议，或者被拖到了卡萨拉尼的看守所。当他真的接电话时，他往往想谈谈与肯尼亚警察或“青年党”无关的事情。我们谈论他最喜欢的电影，《第一滴血》、尼古拉斯·凯奇主演的《勇闯夺命岛》、任何施瓦辛格的电影。我们谈论他在东利的美好旧时光，那时他可以在咖啡馆里一边喝着骆驼奶茶。
One thing I asked Abdi about-- when people win the regular lottery you always hear stories about how all of a sudden family members are really nice to them, or cousins they haven't spoken to in years start calling to say hi, asking for favors. I wondered if this was the case with Abdi. Here he was sitting in a slum with all these refugees who were in the same terrible situation, and now he had a ticket out. Did people start treating him differently?
我问了阿卜迪一件事——当人们赢得常规彩票时，你总是听到这样的故事：突然间亲戚变得非常好，或者多年没联系的堂兄弟开始打电话问候，请求帮忙。我很好奇阿卜迪是否也是这种情况。他身处贫民窟，和所有同样处境悲惨的难民在一起，现在他拿到了一张离开的门票。人们开始对他另眼相看吗？
Yes, Leo, especially the girls.
是的，利奥，尤其是女孩们。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
This is a very good question.
这是一个非常好的问题。
Abdi is a practicing Muslim, and so were the women he hangs out with. So normally, before, you could only visit them in a kind of formal courtship visit at their home. No having girls over to his place, now hanging out in public.
阿卜迪是虔诚的穆斯林，他来往的女性也是如此。所以通常情况下，以前，你只能在她们家里进行某种正式的求婚访问。不能让女孩去他家，也不能在公共场合闲逛。
The difference now, since I won the green card lottery, is that they are trying to come to my house.
现在不同了，自从我赢了绿卡抽奖，她们正试图来我家。
He's talking about before the police raids started, when life was relatively normal in Eastleigh.
他说的是在警察突袭开始之前，当东利的生活还比较正常的时候。
So I just hear someone coming up the stairs and knocking at my door, and saying, hey, Abdi, how have you been? And it's a lady. And, yeah, she sits right next to your bed and it's all about the conversation. She's trying to do anything to attract you with the sweet words.
所以我只是听到有人上楼敲我的门，说，嘿，阿卜迪，你怎么样？是一个女士。然后，是的，她就坐在我的床边，全是关于聊天的话题。她试图用甜言蜜语做任何事来吸引你。
Do you have a girlfriend? When do you want to marry? What type of girls do you want? Now you're going to America, you need a wife. When you go to America, please let me be the first person you get in touch. Because I'm here, and I don't have a husband.
你有女朋友吗？你想什么时候结婚？你喜欢什么样的女孩？现在你要去美国了，你需要一个妻子。当你去美国时，请让我成为第一个你联系的人。因为我在这里，我没有丈夫。
Are you thinking about any of these girls? Maybe something could happen.
你在考虑这些女孩中的任何一个吗？也许会发生点什么。
[LAUGHS] Yes. I really am attracted to one of these girls. She's really beautiful, cute. She's Somali, but she has finished high school in Nairobi. The good thing about her is that she speaks English.
[笑] 是的。我确实被其中一个女孩吸引了。她真的很漂亮，可爱。她是索马里人，但在内罗毕读完了高中。她的好处是她会说英语。
She is really, I think, my type. She likes to read a lot, you know? She has a different character. The rest of Somali girls are very shy, but this pretty girl-- she gives me all this confidence, you know? And she allows me to go to her, and she allows me to hang out with her in downtown Nairobi wherever possible, you know? So I-- yeah. I think I fall in love.
我想她真的是我的类型。她喜欢看书，你知道吗？她有不同的性格。其他的索马里女孩非常害羞，但这个漂亮的女孩——她给了我所有的自信，你知道吗？她允许我去找她，她允许我在内罗毕市中心尽可能地和她闲逛，你知道吗？所以我想，是的，我坠入爱河了。
Well, congratulations. That's one piece of good news.
好吧，恭喜。这是一个好消息。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Yeah. But unfortunately, for the last four weeks we haven't seen each other.
是的。但不幸的是，在过去的四周里我们没能见面。
May 1st, 82 days and counting. Abdi cautiously ventures out of the apartment building for the first time in weeks. He heads downtown to central Nairobi, where life is continuing as normal. It's a stressful journey, but he's able to buy a couple of gallons of clean water and some cans of beans to bring home. He says it's amazing how good these taste to him and Hassan. He tells me he's getting more and more worried about the paperwork he still has to get together for his interview, his medical records and transcripts from his university. And there's one piece of paper that terrifies him.
5月1日，倒计时82天。阿卜迪几周来第一次谨慎地走出公寓楼。他前往内罗毕市中心，那里生活一如往常。这是一段紧张的旅程，但他还是买了几加仑纯净水和一些罐装豆子带回家。他说对他和哈桑来说，这些东西尝起来好极了。他告诉我他越来越担心面试所需的文件，他的医疗记录和大学成绩单。有一张纸让他感到恐惧。
One of the US embassy requirements is to get a police certificate, something called a certificate of good conduct.
美国大使馆的要求之一是获得警察证明，即所谓的“品行证明”。
What this basically is, is proof from Kenyan law enforcement that Abdi isn't a criminal. Abdi doesn't have a record, so this shouldn't be a big deal, except for the place he has to go to get the official certificate, the headquarters of the Kenyan police.
这基本上是证明阿卜迪不是罪犯的来自肯尼亚执法部门的证明。阿卜迪没有犯罪记录，所以这本来不是什么大不了的事，除了他必须去拿官方证明的地方——肯尼亚警察总部。
So that scares you a lot. Thousands of Somalis are being held as we speak, and they're waiting for their return to Somalia, or some of them are waiting for their return to the camps. So when I am thinking of jumping into a bus and headed to headquarters, stepping in there and saying, hey guys, I need a police letter, my heart is already pounding.
那确实让你很害怕。成千上万的索马里人正如我们所说的那样被关押，等待返回索马里，或者等待返回营地。所以当我想着跳上一辆巴士前往总部，走进那里说，嘿伙计们，我需要一封警察信，我的心已经在狂跳了。
For weeks Abdi had been talking to me about this, telling me about how worried he was about having to go into the belly of the beast. Finally, on a Tuesday morning in May, 77 days before his interview, he gets up early, gets together every idea he has to prove he's a legal refugee, says goodbye to Hassan, and takes a bus to police headquarters. He walks in, waits for his name to be called, and walks up to the window where he faces a Kenyan police officer. And what he encounters is not brutal police tactics, but bureaucracy.
几周来阿卜迪一直在跟我谈论这件事，告诉我他有多担心必须进入那个“野兽的腹中”。最终，在五月的一个星期二早上，距离面试还有77天，他早起，带上所有能证明他是合法难民的证明，和哈桑道别，坐公交车去了警察总部。他走了进去，等待名字被叫到，走到窗口面对一名肯尼亚警察。他遇到的不是警察的暴行，而是官僚主义。
He was telling me, there's nothing that I can do but take your paper and send it to UNHCR, and then I have to wait for them to come back to me. Even it can take more than five months, he tells me.
他告诉我，我什么也做不了，只能收下你的文件，把它发给联合国难民署，然后我必须等待他们给我反馈。他告诉我，这甚至可能需要五个多月。
Five months. Way too long for Abdi to have it in time for his interview on July 22nd.
五个月。对于在7月22日面试的阿卜迪来说，时间太长了。
The guy there was not friendly. He was really, really fierce, and I was frozen with fear. And finally, I tell him, wait, just listen to me, gentlemen. You're talking about five months, sir, but that's not what I'm talking about. If I don't get this police certificate, they will not give me-- or issue a visa for me, all right? So please, is it possible? And he was telling me, there's nothing that I can do for you. It's going to take more than five months.
那个在那里的家伙很不友好。他真的很凶，我吓得僵住了。最终，我告诉他，等等，听我说，先生。你在说五个月，但那不是我在说的。如果我拿不到这个警察证明，他们就不会给我——或者签发签证，好吧？所以请问，有可能吗？他告诉我，我什么也帮不了你。这需要五个多月。
There's no possibility of you going into a later position with the US embassy, is there?
你没有可能去美国大使馆争取更晚的位置，对吧？
No.
没有。
It doesn't happen. If you delay your interview, that's the end of it. Some other people will grab the visa. Yeah. That's going to be a doom.
这不会发生。如果你推迟面试，那一切就结束了。其他人会抢走签证。是的，那将是灭顶之灾。
It's going to be a doom, Abdi says. And I felt that too. Up to this point it seemed like if Abdi could just hold on long enough to get to his embassy interview, he'd make it to America. Now, all bets were off. Now, unless this changed, there was no way.
阿卜迪说，那将是灭顶之灾。我也感到了这一点。到目前为止，似乎只要阿卜迪能坚持到足够久去参加大使馆面试，他就能去美国。现在，一切都成了未知数。现在，除非情况改变，否则没戏了。
Leo Hornak. Abdi decides to keep going back to police headquarters every few weeks, despite the risk, despite how frightening it is, to see if one time maybe he gets a different answer. What happens next in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
利奥·霍纳克。阿卜迪决定尽管冒着风险，尽管过程多么吓人，还是每隔几周就回到警察总部，看看有没有可能得到不同的答案。接下来会发生什么，过一会儿，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program we're hearing the story of Abdi Nor, a Somali refugee who escaped to Kenya. And then he won what amounts to a golden ticket to move to the United States and become an American, but only if he's able to make it to an interview at the US embassy, with all the right paperwork, all done perfectly, so he can cash in that golden ticket.
这是《This American Life》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天在节目中，我们听到的是索马里难民阿卜迪·诺尔的故事，他逃到了肯尼亚。然后他赢得了相当于移居美国并成为美国人的“金票”，前提是他能够带着所有完美无缺的必要文件，准时参加美国大使馆的面试，这样他才能兑现那张金票。
The United Nations has reported that the number of people around the world displaced from their homes because of conflict and persecution is at an all time high. It's over 65 million people, the largest number the UN has ever recorded. Abdi, of course, is one of those people.
联合国报告称，由于冲突和迫害，全世界流离失所的人数处于历史最高水平。超过6500万人，这是联合国记录到的最大数字。当然，阿卜迪就是其中之一。
He's Muslim, from a country with a proven history of terrorism. There are proposals, of course, in this presidential race to ban Muslims or people from countries like that from emigrating to the United States, even if, like Abdi, they are running from terrorists and aren't terrorists themselves. Anyway, Leo Hornick continues this story.
他是穆斯林，来自一个有恐怖主义历史的国家。当然，在这次总统选举中，有人提议禁止穆斯林或来自类似国家的人移民美国，即使他们像阿卜迪一样，是在逃离恐怖分子，而不是恐怖分子本人。总之，利奥·霍纳克继续讲述这个故事。
May 12th, t-minus 71 days to Abdi's embassy interview. Abdi gets on a bus home from school, and this time runs into another danger. Not the police, not al-Shabaab themselves, but the fear of al-Shabaab.
5月12日，距离阿卜迪大使馆面试还有71天。阿卜迪下课坐公交车回家，这次又遇到了危险。不是警察，也不是“青年党”本身，而是对“青年党”的恐惧。
The bus is so crowded with people. And there are these two ladies watching me.
公交车上挤满了人。有两个女士盯着我看。
Abdi looks around and realizes he's the only Somali. People can tell. Somalis look different. And a Somali with a backpack on, on a public bus-- he knows what people are thinking.
阿卜迪环顾四周，意识到他是唯一的索马里人。人们认得出来。索马里人看起来不同。而一个背着背包的索马里人，在公交车上——他知道人们在想什么。
They are watching my hands. They're thinking, like, when is this guy putting his hand into that bag and start to blow up? These ladies then started shouting at the driver, have you made sure there's no bomb in that bag?
她们盯着我的手。她们在想，这家伙什么时候把手伸进包里然后引爆炸弹？这些女士开始对司机喊，你确定那个包里没有炸弹吗？
I had to fight back. And I say, listen lady, wait a minute. I'm not what you think I am, you know? No. There's no bomb in here. I'm not one of those people. I'm a student and I'm carrying my books. It's quite embarrassing. And at the same time, I feel fear because everyone in there had very cautious eyes on me.
我不得不反击。我说，听着，女士，等一下。我不是你想的那样，你知道吗？没有。包里没有炸弹。我不是那种人。我是个学生，我背着书。这太令人尴尬了。同时，我感到恐惧，因为车里每个人都用非常谨慎的目光盯着我。
In Kenya, because people don't trust the police, mobs will take justice into their own hands. For example, if a shopkeeper yells "thief" on the street, strangers might grab the person and beat them. And it's not unheard of for people to die this way.
在肯尼亚，因为人们不信任警察，暴民会采取私刑。例如，如果店主在街上喊“小偷”，陌生人可能会抓住那个人并殴打他们。人们以此方式丧生也并非闻所未闻。
A man in the back of the past chimes in. "Why is he there," he shouts. Kick him out."
车后座的一个男人附和道：“他为什么在那儿？把他踢出去。”
I tried as much as I can to calm them down, and they were ignoring me. And then the driver turns his head and tells me, boy, step out of my car or I'll call the police. And you know, we weren't in little Mogadishu. We weren't in downtown. We were in the middle. And in the middle, what I mean in the middle, is exactly the Pangani police station.
我尽可能地安抚他们，但他们不理我。然后司机转过头告诉我，男孩，下车，否则我就报警。你知道，我们当时不在小摩加迪沙，也不在市中心。我们在中间。而我说在中间，指的正是潘加尼警察局。
This is the police station Somali terrorist bombed two weeks earlier.
这是两周前索马里恐怖分子炸毁的警察局。
What do you think? If they kick me out there with a bag, standing there near the police station, what's going to happen? They can shoot me to death. I said to the driver, wait a minute. You want to know what's in here? And then I had to unzip my bag and bring everything out, the books, the papers, showed him the pen, the student ID. Everything I brought out.
你怎么想？如果他们把我踢在那里，带着个包，站在警察局附近，会发生什么？他们可以开枪打死我。我对司机说，等一下。你想知道这里面是什么吗？我不得不解开包，把所有东西拿出来，书、纸、给他看笔、学生证。我拿出了所有东西。
And then I hang the bag upside-down and showed him. Do you see anything in there? And then it looked like the driver was kind of satisfied, and he looked straight, and he drove the car a little bit faster.
然后我把包倒过来展示给他。你看到里面有什么东西吗？然后司机看起来有点满意了，他目视前方，车开快了一点。
Four days later, May 16th, 67 days to the interview, al-Shabaab blows up two buses. It's a big deal. They were in a central market. At least 12 dead, more than 70 injured. Abdi's sure the police will be out in force, and he hunkers down at home for a while.
四天后，5月16日，距离面试还有67天，“青年党”炸毁了两辆巴士。这事很大。它们就在中心市场。至少12人死亡，70多人受伤。阿卜迪肯定警察会大举出动，他缩在家里一段时间。
[PHONE RINGING]
[电话铃声]
Hey, Abdi, what's up? How's it going?
嘿，阿卜迪，怎么了？还好吗？
Leo, it's good. How are you?
利奥，很好。你呢？
Yeah. Not too bad at all. Could you tell me the date? And then we can start.
是的。还不错。你能告诉我今天的日期吗？然后我们可以开始了。
The date?
日期？
Yeah.
是的。
It's May 17th, 2014. And last night, after that explosion, there was a massive operation in little Mogadishu. They have knocked at our house. It was like 2:00 last night. We haven't opened. They just kept knocking, and they were thinking, like, there's nobody here. And then they have moved.
今天是2014年5月17日。昨晚，在那次爆炸后，小摩加迪沙发生了大规模行动。他们敲了我们的门。大约是昨晚两点。我们没有开门。他们一直敲，以为没人。然后他们离开了。
So-- hang on. So they kind of-- if they just don't get any answer, then they think it's empty?
等等。所以他们——如果没得到任何回应，他们就以为是空的？
Yes. The thing is that, Eastleigh is not like before. Now there are no more people at all. 80% have gone. That's what I think. It was like 50% before, now it's 80%. Most buildings are empty. So these days, when they keep knocking and nobody's opening, they're thinking, like, people here have moved.
是的。事实是，东利不像以前了。现在根本没人了。80%的人走了。这就是我想的。之前是50%，现在是80%。大多数建筑都是空的。所以这些天，当他们敲门没人开的时候，他们以为这里的人搬走了。
So, yes, that's what we did last night. None of us opened. There was no light in our house because these guys, they are listening to the movements. They're watching if there's any movement in the windows. They are seeing if there's a light or something. Just something like that shows them there's a life here. So that's what we do. We don't show there's a life. It's totally blackouts.
所以，是的，这就是我们昨晚做的。我们没人开门。我们屋里没有灯光，因为这些家伙，他们在听动静。他们在观察窗户里有没有动静。他们在看有没有灯光之类的。只要显示这里有人生活就行。所以这就是我们做的。我们不显示有人生活。完全黑暗。
[PHONE RINGING]
[电话铃声]
Good evening, Leo.
晚上好，利奥。
Hey, Abdi. How are you?
嘿，阿卜迪。你怎么样？
I'm good. I'm good, Leo. How are you?
很好。很好，利奥。你呢？
Good. I'm pleased to hear it. I know that you had a tough-- a very difficult evening. Do you want to say what the date is and tell me what happened?
很好。听到你很好我很高兴。我知道你度过了一个艰难的——非常困难的夜晚。你想说一下日期并告诉我发生了什么吗？
May 19. Now the time is 8:45. All I can say, Leo, is that I haven't slept for the last, I'm going to say, 30 hours or more, because the police raid has increased. They have come and taken so many people from our neighborhood. And we have realized that this is not the ordinary police. They have changed something.
5月19日。现在是8点45分。我只能说，利奥，我已经至少30多个小时没睡觉了，因为警察突袭增加了。他们来过，从我们社区带走了很多人。我们意识到这不是普通的警察。他们变了。
These guys, they don't negotiate on cash. Everything has changed. And they're not going into any negotiation at all. They throw you in the back of their trucks and drive away so many, so many refugees.
这些家伙，他们不谈现金。一切都变了。他们根本不进行谈判。他们把你扔进卡车后面，带走成批成批的难民。
And how are you finding this out? How do you know this?
你是怎么知道这些的？你是怎么知道的？
Well, I told you already about that girl. She's my-- I'm going to say she's my girlfriend now. But she has a Kenyan national ID. The text message she sent me here, it says, hey, they have been with me for like 15 minutes, where she was sleeping, her room.
哦，我跟你说过了那个女孩。她——我可以说她现在是我的女朋友。但她有肯尼亚国民身份证。她发给我的短信说，嘿，他们在我住的地方待了大约15分钟。
And one of them said, you're not supposed to be a Somali. You're a Kenyan, so you can be my wife. That's one of the policemen-- what one of the policemen said when she showed them her Kenyan national ID. I'm taking all the Somalis, so you'd be lonely here. Just come and you will be safe. You will live with me. And she said, please leave me alone.
他们中的一个说，你不应该是个索马里人。你是肯尼亚人，你可以做我的妻子。这是一个警察——当她给他们看肯尼亚身份证时，那个警察说的。我要带走所有索马里人，你会孤身一人在这里。跟我走，你会安全的。你会和我生活在一起。她说，请别理我。
They took everyone else in the compound where she lived who had a refugee ID. She lived with other girls, and the other girls don't have the national IDs, so they forced the girls out. They have finally forced the girls out.
他们带走了她住处的所有其他人，那些人只有难民证。她和别的女孩一起住，那些女孩没有国民身份证，所以他们强行把女孩们带走了。他们最终强行带走了她们。
I tried to confirm this with his girlfriend, but she didn't want to talk to me about it. Abdi says the police took her roommates that night but left her behind.
我试图从他女朋友那里证实这一点，但她不想跟我谈这个。阿卜迪说那天晚上警察带走了她的室友，却留下了她。
So, what, she's alone now? What's the situation?
所以，她现在是一个人了？情况怎么样？
She is alone. Yes. So Leo, yes, that last night Hassan and I, we didn't know where to go. We could hear all those sounds, the knock of our gate, the shouts, the bullets that were being fired into the doors of people. At one moment I was thinking, like, go under your bed. And the other moment I was thinking, like, if they find you here they're going to kill you. I was like, this is-- I don't know. I've never been in such a stressful situation.
她是一个人。是的。所以利奥，是的，昨晚哈桑和我，我们不知道该去哪。我们可以听到所有那些声音，敲门声、喊叫声，向人们门上开枪的声音。有一刻我想，躲在床下吧。另一刻我想，如果他们发现你在那，他们会杀了你的。我当时，我不知道。我从来没经历过这么大的压力。
So if you were to look outside the building right now, what would you see?
所以如果你现在看看窗外，会看到什么？
Leo, to be honest-- Leo--
利奥，老实说——利奥——
I'm not asking you to. I know it's dangerous. But just if I could-- help me imagine.
我不是让你去看。我知道很危险。但只要我能——帮我想象一下。
Leo, to be honest, if I just look through my window there's nothing that I can see, I'm telling you. There's nothing that I can see. All the lights are off. Even there's no street light here now.
利奥，说实话，如果我从窗户往外看，什么也看不到，我告诉你。什么也看不到。灯全关了。甚至连路灯都没了。
It's totally, totally dark. There's only this light coming from the laptop. You have to put lots of things on the windows so that they cannot even see-- that's what I'm doing right now, so that they cannot even see the light from my laptop.
完全是漆黑一片。只有笔记本电脑的光。你必须在窗户上放很多东西，这样他们甚至看不到——这就是我正在做的，这样他们甚至看不到我电脑发出的光。
But Leo, I don't know. I don't know why they come at night. Why is that? Because they don't want us to go sleep? Why don't they come during the day? They usually come the same time, 2:30. 2:30, you know? And that's exactly when Somali women and children are all asleep, and then these guys are coming. They kick the door open, telling you, wake up, terrorists. Wake up. Why are you sleeping?
但利奥，我不知道。我不知道他们为什么晚上来。为什么？因为他们不想让我们睡觉？他们为什么不白天来？他们通常在同一时间来，两点半。两点半，你知道吗？而那正是索马里妇女和孩子都在睡觉的时候，然后这些家伙来了。他们踹开门，大喊，醒醒，恐怖分子。醒醒。为什么在睡觉？
Mm-hm.
嗯。
They are coming back every night. What the hell is going on? Why don't they at least-- if they are doing an operation, why don't they come at one time and finish the whole things? You know, they are killing us. They are killing us by fearing.
他们每天晚上都回来。到底是怎么回事？他们为什么不至少——如果他们在执行任务，为什么不一次来就把所有事做完？你知道，他们在杀我们。他们在用恐惧杀我们。
In this situation, it must be easy for al-Shabaab to get supporters, I guess? People who have some-- maybe a little bit of sympathy with their ideas?
在这种情况下，对“青年党”来说争取支持者一定很容易，我想？那些有一些——也许对他们的想法有一点点同情的人？
Did you read or did you hear about the young men who were deported from Kenya to Somalia, have already joined al-Shabaab?
你读到或听到关于那些从肯尼亚被驱逐回索马里的年轻人已经加入“青年党”了吗？
No, I didn't see that.
没有，我没看到。
They are coming from the border, already attacking Kenya as revenge because the Kenyans have really mistreated so many women and children and so many young men. Kenya has really given a very good opportunity to these al-Shabaab guys because they are getting what they wanted. They are getting the young men that they were looking for.
他们从边境回来，已经在袭击肯尼亚作为报复，因为肯尼亚人确实虐待了太多妇女、儿童和年轻人。肯尼亚确实给了这些“青年党”家伙一个很好的机会，因为他们得到了他们想要的。他们得到了他们一直在寻找的年轻人。
Yeah. Well, I wish I could say more, but I think there's nothing more I can say right now.
是的。好吧，我希望能说更多，但我认为我现在没什么可说的了。
I know all I need is some sleep. I don't know if you can feel that.
我知道我所需要的只是一些睡眠。我不知道你是否能感受到。
I can. I can. I can hear you feel very stressed. I hope you get some sleep, and keep safe as well. As safe as you can, with your good luck, I mean.
我能。我能。我能听出你压力很大。我希望你能睡个好觉，也要保持安全。正如你所能的那样，祝你好运。
Thanks, Leo. Good luck to you, too.
谢谢，利奥。也祝你好运。
Days go by. Abdi and Hassan do their best to keep their spirits up and entertain themselves. They read books. They watch Lost and Walking Dead . It's one of the weird quirks of Eastleigh, that even if food runs short you can still have good broadband internet.
日子一天天过去。阿卜迪和哈桑尽力保持精神振奋，自娱自乐。他们读书。他们看《迷失》和《行尸走肉》。东利有一个奇怪的怪癖，即使食物短缺，你仍然可以拥有良好的宽带互联网。
They even built makeshift barbells out of old milk cans they filled with sand and stones, and start working out.
他们甚至用装满沙子和石头的旧奶罐做了简易杠铃，开始健身。
[GRUNTING] One, two, three--
[哼声] 一，二，三——
And they do one of Abdi's favorite things.
他们还做了一件阿卜迪最爱的事情。
You want me to go and get--
你想让我去拿——
Yes. OK.
是的。好吧。
Listen to music.
听音乐。
[MUSIC - WHAM!, "CARELESS WHISPER"]
[音乐 - 威猛乐队, "Careless Whisper"]
Back in Somalia, if al-Shabaab caught you with MP3s on your phone, they would flog you, or they could even kill you for it. They believe most music is sinful. But Abdi always took a risk. He kept his music collection on a secret SIM card hidden under the mattress.
回到索马里，如果“青年党”抓到你手机里有MP3，他们会鞭打你，甚至因为这个杀你。他们认为大多数音乐是有罪的。但阿卜迪总是冒着风险。他把他的音乐收藏保存在藏在床垫下的秘密SIM卡里。
This song is called "Careless Whisper." Gives me some good memories, because in Somalia we really had very few Western songs, and there was one time that they got this song and made it into Somali. They translate it.
这首歌叫《Careless Whisper》。给了我一些美好的回忆，因为在索马里我们西方歌曲非常少，有一次他们拿到了这首歌并把它翻唱成索马里语。他们翻译了它。
Wow.
哇。
Yeah. Yeah. I would love to play you that. I don't know if you-- let me think where we can get it. Uh, yeah. Um--
是的。是的。我很想放给你听。我不知道是否——让我想想我们在哪里能弄到它。呃，是的。嗯——
[MUSIC - MUKTAR IDI RAMADAN, "CARELESS WHISPER"]
[音乐 - Muktar Idi Ramadan, "Careless Whisper"]
To be very honest, I have so many songs on my phone, but most of them are very, very old. I really enjoy them because I remember my father on the beautiful days in Somalia. He used to play these songs because he had this big radio. I'm talking about the '90s when I was a pretty young guy. And my father used to sit like this, he's leaning against the wall, his big radio is right next to him. And next to him is a flask full of hot tea, with his khat. And the khat is the small leaves that Somalis eat as a stimulant. And next to him is also a bowl full of milk.
说实话，我的手机里有很多歌，但大多数都是非常、非常老的。我真的很喜欢它们，因为我想起了父亲在索马里那些美好的日子。他过去常放这些歌，因为他有这台大收音机。我说的是90年代，那时我还很小。父亲常像这样坐着，靠在墙上，他的大收音机就在他旁边。他旁边是一个装满热茶的保温瓶，还有他的恰特草。恰特草是索马里人当作兴奋剂咀嚼的小叶子。他旁边还有一个装满牛奶的碗。
Oh my god. My father, when he has all that stuff, he's in heaven. He's smiling. He gets his finger on the tape and he makes us quiet. He says, shut up and just enjoy.
天哪。父亲，当他有所有那些东西时，他就到了天堂。他在笑。他把手指放在磁带上，让我们安静。他说，闭嘴，好好享受。
During all this, Abdi did leave the house sometimes, but only for a very specific reason, either to go to an important class he couldn't miss, or to go to the police headquarters and try his luck again getting the certificate he needs for his interview. Then, on May 29th, with 54 days and counting, Abdi sends me this recording.
在此期间，阿卜迪有时确实会离开房子，但仅仅是因为一个特定的原因，要么去上不能错过的重要的课，要么去警察总部再碰碰运气，争取面试所需的证明。然后，在5月29日，倒计时54天，阿卜迪发给了我这段录音。
Hi. This is Abdi. [EXHALES STRONGLY] I have great news to declare, so let me just--
嗨。我是阿卜迪。 [用力呼气] 我有好消息要宣布，所以让我——
[DOOR OPENING AND CLOSING]
[门打开又关上]
I'm so excited! Oh, my god. I'm really different today. My police clearance is done.
我太兴奋了！天哪。我今天完全不同了。我的警察许可完成了。
Let me say that again. My police clearance is done. I'm looking at my 10 fingers. They're all black because I'm still wearing the black ink for the fingerprints, and I'm not sorry about it.
让我再说一遍。我的警察许可完成了。我看着我的10个手指。它们全是黑的，因为我的指纹上还带着黑色墨水，但我一点也不遗憾。
I smell the US visa. I smell it. I smell it. I see July 22 coming. This was the only problem. I dealt with it. It's done.
我闻到了美国签证的味道。我闻到了。我闻到了。我看到了7月22号的到来。这是唯一的问题。我解决了它。完成了。
At this point, Abdi is a shoo-in. It's almost hard to believe after all the obstacles, but he calls up the embassy, talks through all the paperwork, and they tell him he's good to go, and they'll see him on the 22nd. And his tune on our nightly phone calls totally changes. From this--
此时，阿卜迪成了稳操胜券的人。在经历所有障碍后几乎难以置信，但他打电话给大使馆，谈了所有文件，他们告诉他一切准备就绪，22号见。他在我们每晚通话中的语调完全变了。从这个——
My heart's broke, you know? I'm feeling like, OK, I'm not-- you're not going to make it.
我的心碎了，你知道吗？我觉得，好吧，我不会——你不会成功的。
To this.
变成这个。
Now I am in love with the American culture. I'm in love with their beautiful roads and streets, you know, houses. I'm in love with everything, everything in the US that's going on.
现在我爱上了美国文化。我爱上了他们美丽的道路和街道，你知道，房子。我爱上了美国正在发生的一切，一切。
Do you sometimes worry that maybe you're so in love with this place that it might disappoint you when you reach there? Many people who reach America have a very tough time.
你有时担心吗，也许你太爱这个地方，当你到达那里时它可能会让你失望？许多到达美国的人处境非常艰难。
Mm-hm. No. Um, I don't worry about that because I know, whatever I have been through, they have never been through. I've been a refugee. I've been hiding from police. I've been hiding from Shabaab. I've been hiding from so many armed groups.
嗯。不。嗯，我不担心那个，因为我知道，无论我经历过什么，他们从来没经历过。我当过难民。我躲避过警察。我躲避过“青年党”。我躲避过那么多武装团体。
I have had enough trouble. I have had enough disappointment. America is an opportunity. So I will take my chances.
我受够了麻烦。我受够了失望。美国是一个机会。所以我愿意碰碰运气。
And America's an opportunity not just for Abdi, but his whole family.
美国不仅对阿卜迪是一个机会，对他全家也是。
My mother is in Somalia. She's in Mogadishu, the most dangerous city in the world. And so every call that's coming from Mogadishu, I pick up really with shaky hands.
我母亲在索马里。她在摩加迪沙，世界上最危险的城市。所以每一个来自摩加迪沙的电话，我接起时手都在颤抖。
Abdi hasn't seen his mother in more than three years. She lives in a tiny, rundown shack made of corrugated tin, and she doesn't always have access to enough food or clean water. If Abdi gets to America, he hopes he can make some money. And even if he can't protect her from violence, he can at least help her to get a better place with clean water and three meals a day.
阿卜迪已经三年多没见过他母亲了。她住在一个由波纹铁皮制成的破烂小棚屋里，并不总是能获得足够的食物或清洁水。如果阿卜迪去了美国，他希望能挣些钱。即使他不能保护她免受暴力，他至少可以帮她换个带清洁水、一日三餐更好的住所。
I spoke to my mother yesterday evening. She asked, boy, when are you going out of that country? And I said, Mom, I got 52 days. 52 days. I need your prayers. And she said, oh my god. He has got 52 days. I'm praying for you, boy.
昨天傍晚我和母亲通了话。她问，孩子，你什么时候离开那个国家？我说，妈妈，还有52天。52天。我需要你的祈祷。她说，天哪。还有52天。我会为你祈祷的，孩子。
And I know, like I am right now, she's counting the days. It's going to be something that'll make her proud, that'll make her survive. She's really sending all her prayers towards me.
我知道，就像我一样，她在倒数日子。这将是一件让她自豪、让她活下去的事情。她确实在为我祈祷。
Abdi's older brother, Hassan, has also applied for the visa lottery. Like Abdi, he's worked for years on his English. He came to Kenya years before Abdi. Now he's getting ready to live alone again.
阿卜迪的哥哥哈桑也申请了签证抽奖。像阿卜迪一样，他为英语学习努力多年。他在阿卜迪之前几年就来到肯尼亚了。现在他又要准备独自生活了。
Hassan, is there a part of you that thinks-- you know, just a little part of you-- that is a bit jealous about Abdi? Because you both worked hard. And Abdi has got this not through hard work, but by luck.
哈桑，你心里有没有觉得——你知道，只是那么一点点——对阿卜迪有点嫉妒？因为你们都努力了。而阿卜迪得到这个不是通过努力，而是通过运气。
Actually, if I tell you, I don't have the lease jealousy at all. If we get, two of us, visa to get out of here, it will even be better. But if someone told me right now, there is one visa, which one of you will take it? I would say Abdi, because he's new to this country and I know how we are so fearful at night, and I know how he can't sleep at night.
实际上，如果我告诉你，我一点都不嫉妒。如果我们两个人能拿到签证离开这里，那会更好。但如果现在有人告诉我，这里只有一张签证，你们俩谁要？我会说阿卜迪，因为他来到这个国家时间不长，我知道我们在晚上有多么恐惧，我知道他晚上有多睡不着觉。
For him to get a visa is my biggest pleasure. Yeah, there's luck there. But luck can't be fair.
他能拿到签证是我最大的快乐。是的，有运气成分。但运气可以是公平的。
June 4th, 48 days and counting. Abdi goes into the stairwell to use the bathroom and finds a police officer standing there who calls for backup. The officer doesn't ask for a bribe. He lets Abdi go. Abdi has no idea why.
6月4日，倒计时48天。阿卜迪走进楼梯间去厕所，发现一个警察站在那儿呼叫支援。警察没要贿赂。他放阿卜迪走了。阿卜迪不知道为什么。
June 8th, 44 days to go. Abdi tells me, apparently the police have started raiding during the day, which is a change. He avoided them because he was at class.
6月8日，倒计时44天。阿卜迪告诉我，显然警察已经开始在白天突袭了，这是一个变化。他避开了他们，因为他在上课。
June 15th, 37 days to go. Abdi hears on the radio that dozens of masked al-Shabaab gunmen bombed a police station, stole its weapons, and went on a rampage in a town on the coast killing at least 48 people. Abdi and Hassan brace for more police raids. July 7th, 15 days to go.
6月15日，倒计时37天。阿卜迪在收音机里听到，几十名蒙面“青年党”枪手炸毁了一个警察局，偷走了武器，并在沿海一个小镇上大开杀戒，至少造成48人死亡。阿卜迪和哈桑为更多的警察突袭做准备。7月7日，倒计时15天。
Leo, I'm telling you, they have chased me with machetes, with stones--
利奥，我告诉你，他们挥舞着砍刀、石头追赶我——
Abdi, you're kidding.
阿卜迪，你在开玩笑吧。
Yeah, it was only two hours ago.
是的，那仅仅是两小时前。
When Abdi and I speak, he's shaken up. He says he just tried to visit the mosque for the first time in weeks. It's right down the block.
当阿卜迪和我通话时，他受到惊吓。他说他刚才几周来第一次试着去清真寺。就在那条街上。
It was, like, only ten steps away from my house. And then there's this, like, 50 armed young men. They were armed with machetes and with rocks in their hands. And they started chasing me and throwing those stones. And then I started running towards the mosque.
它离我家只有十步之遥。然后有50个武装的年轻人。他们拿着砍刀和石头。他们开始追我，扔石头。然后我开始向清真寺跑。
The mob was a bunch of Kenyans attacking Somalis at random on the streets.
那伙人是一群肯尼亚人，正在街上随机袭击索马里人。
Yeah. They caught up with others. They were beating these guys, and I couldn't look back.
是的。他们追上了其他人。他们正在殴打那些人，我不敢回头。
Oh wow.
哦，哇。
I threw myself-- I threw myself into the mosque and then somebody closed the gate. And the sheikh, cleric, he was like, please calm down. If these people want to kill us, I think we will go-- we will all go to heaven because Allah says, if we die in the mosque, that's it. We'll go straight to heaven.
我冲——我冲进了清真寺，然后有人关上了门。谢赫（教长）说，请冷静。如果这些人想杀了我们，我想我们都会——我们都会去天堂，因为真主说，如果我们死在清真寺里，就是这样。我们会直接去天堂。
Did you expect to die?
你当时以为自己会死吗？
I did.
是的。
July 17th, five days to go. The woman sending in money from America wires cash for his interview fee, $320. And then finally, July 21st, one day to go.
7月17日，倒计时五天。从美国寄钱的那个女人汇来了他的面试费，320美元。最后，7月21日，倒计时一天。
It's actually not days. It's now hours left to my interview.
实际上不是几天。现在只剩下几个小时到面试了。
10 hours and 53 minutes, to be precise. It's at 7:30 tomorrow morning.
准确地说是10小时53分钟。明天早上7点半。
I'm not going to bed anymore. I'm not going to sleep. I'm sure about that. Tomorrow is going to change my life. It's going to change my life to be the happiest person, or else it's going to change my life to be the most devastated man on Earth. So it's these two.
我再也不去睡觉了。我不睡了。我很确定。明天将改变我的一生。它要么改变我的一生，让我成为最幸福的人，要么改变我的一生，让我成为地球上最绝望的人。所以就是这两种情况。
Tomorrow night, I'm coming back to this room, breaking everything, smashing everything right here because I'm happy, or I'm angry. In both situations I'll break these things, I know. I will just give a punch into my laptop.
明晚，我回到这个房间，破坏一切，砸碎这里的一切，因为我很高兴，或者我很愤怒。无论哪种情况我都会砸这些东西，我知道。我只要给我的笔记本电脑一拳。
[LAUGHS] I have to say, Abdi, I'm really excited for you. I'm just wishing you good luck, you know, with all my heart.
[笑] 我必须说，阿卜迪，我真的为你感到兴奋。我只是全心全意祝你好运。
Thank you. Thank you.
谢谢。谢谢。
I'm going to leave you and let you prepare. And I can't wait to speak tomorrow.
我要挂了，让你准备。我等不及要和你在明天通话了。
I wish I would talk to you smiling, not really have that, notice that.
希望我能笑着和你说话，而不是那个，注意到那个。
I think you will be smiling. That's what I expect.
我想你会笑的。我就是这么期待的。
Oh, thank you. Thank you very much.
哦，谢谢。非常感谢。
OK. So um, while I was brushing my teeth this morning I got a text message, and it was from Abdi. "Hi. Very bad news. They gave me a red paper that said, visa rejected." And um, yeah. We text messaged backwards and forwards, and um, the last message he sent to me, which was a few hours ago, was "this is my worst day on Earth."
好的。那么嗯，今天早上我在刷牙时收到一条短信，是阿卜迪发来的。“嗨。非常坏的消息。他们给了我一张红纸，说签证被拒了。” 然后嗯，是的。我们来回发短信，而嗯，他几小时前发给我的最后一条短信是“这是我地球上最糟糕的一天”。
I couldn't get hold of Abdi for a day. When I finally did talk to him, he walked me through what happened. Abdi arrived hours early. The waiting room was filled with other lottery winners. One by one they were called in, and one by one, Abdi says, they came out grinning. Then Abdi's number was called. This was it, window 9.
我有整整一天没联系上阿卜迪。当我最终和他交谈时，他带我回顾了发生的事情。阿卜迪提前几小时到达。候机室里挤满了其他彩票获胜者。他们一个接一个被叫进去，一个接一个，阿卜迪说，他们都咧着嘴出来了。然后叫到了阿卜迪的号码。就是这个了，9号窗口。
Um, there is this American lady. She was a black American, to be honest. I was really happy because somebody already told me that the ladies are good than the men. So if lady interviews you, you get the visa. So I was thinking, all right, man, you got it.
嗯，有个美国女士。说实话，她是个美国黑人。我真高兴，因为有人已经告诉过我，女人比男人好。所以如果是女人面试你，你就能拿到签证。所以我心想，好啦，兄弟，你拿到它了。
So the first thing she said was, please, can you raise your right hand and swear that everything that you will say is the truth?
所以她说的第一件事是，请，能请你举起右手，发誓你所说的一切都是真实的吗？
Abdi did. He answered a few simple questions.
阿卜迪照做了。他回答了几个简单的问题。
And then she was busy writing something on her computer. I could feel that my legs were shivering.
然后她忙着在电脑上写东西。我能感觉到我的腿在发抖。
Hm.
嗯。
So this is the moment, man. This is the moment that you have been waiting for. And then she said, so, tell me, where did you go to high school? And I said, Mogadishu, Somalia.
所以这是时刻了，兄弟。这是你一直在等待的时刻。然后她说，那么，告诉我，你是在哪里上的高中？我说，摩加迪沙，索马里。
Where'd you go to college? She asked. And he told her his university in Nairobi.
大学是在哪上的？她问。他告诉了她他在内罗毕的大学。
But she said, the transcript that you have here does not have a signature. Did you know that?
但她说，你这里有的成绩单没有签名。你知道吗？
One of his school transcripts didn't have a signature. She took out a pink piece of paper and on the bottom wrote two words, "missing transcript." She handed it to Abdi and said, sorry, I can't give you the visa.
他的一份学校成绩单没有签名。她拿出了一张粉红色的纸，在底部写了两个词：“缺少成绩单”。她把它递给阿卜迪说，对不起，我不能给你签证。
I was looking into her eyes, like, please, come back to me and say, hey, I've changed my mind. Please. Please, God. I need your help. I need luck today.
我看着她的眼睛，像是在说，求求你，回来对我说，嘿，我改变主意了。求求你。求求你，上帝。我需要你的帮助。我今天需要运气。
But the lady didn't change her mind. She picked up her microphone and called the next number.
但那位女士没改变主意。她拿起麦克风叫了下一个号码。
Dazed, Abdi walked outside and sat alone under a tree outside the embassy.
阿卜迪魂不守舍地走出大楼，独自坐在大使馆外的一棵树下。
Because I needed to calm myself and bring myself together, I sat there. I was holding my head, and I was looking at this whole world as the worst place to live. I told myself, hey, are you rejected? Is this real, or am I dreaming? I thought it was like a dream. No. They can't do this. They can't do this.
因为我需要冷静下来，调整自己，我就坐在那儿。我抱着头，看着整个世界，觉得它是最糟糕的生存之地。我对自己说，嘿，你被拒绝了？这是真的，还是我在做梦？我以为这像个梦。不。他们不能这样做。他们不能这样做。
The embassy told him he could send them a signed transcript if he wanted, but they told him not to come back to the embassy. They'd be in touch, maybe. Abdi sent the transcript, even though he was sure he'd missed his chance.
大使馆告诉他，如果想的话可以寄一份签名成绩单，但告诉他别再来大使馆了。他们会联系他的，也许吧。阿卜迪寄了成绩单，尽管他确定自己错过了机会。
Hello, this is Abdi Nor. It's the 1st of August, 2014. An email got into my inbox. It was immigrant visa department at the US embassy, and it tells me, "from our records, your document has been received, and your visa will be sent by tomorrow."
你好，这是阿卜迪·诺尔。今天是2014年8月1日。我的收件箱收到了一封邮件。是美国大使馆移民签证部门发来的，它告诉我说：“根据记录，您的文件已收到，您的签证将在明天寄出。”
Oh my god. This email made me jump over my bed and hit my head onto the ceiling. It's issued. God, I just looked at it again. It's issued! What the hell's going on? It's issued! This big smile was on my face. I've never, ever had such a big smile-- never, ever, ever, ever.
天哪。这封邮件让我从床上跳起来，头撞到了天花板。它签发了。上帝，我又看了一遍。签发了！到底发生了什么？签发了！我脸上露出了灿烂的笑容。我从来没有过这么灿烂的笑容——从来没有，从来没有，从来没有。
[PHONE RINGING]
[电话铃声]
Hey, you.
嘿，你。
Abdi.
阿卜迪。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Oh my god. How are you?
天哪。你怎么样？
I think-- [LAUGHS] Leo--
我想—— [笑] 利奥——
Are you recording this, first, please, before you say-- don't say anything first. Please be recording.
你是在录音吗，首先，求求你，在你说话之前——先别说什么。请一定要在录音。
I am recording, yeah.
我正在录音，是的。
OK, great.
好的，太棒了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
How does it feel to be the owner of a US visa?
作为美国签证的拥有者感觉如何？
Mm-hm. [EXHALES] What was the question again?
嗯。[呼气] 问题是什么来着？
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
Sorry.
抱歉。
You're on a different planet.
你在不同的星球上了。
Oh!
哦！
What does it feel like to be a green card holder? It feels like the dream has just become real. I don't know what sort of-- it feels like I am not a refugee. Now this is not the refugee that was hiding from the police. [LAUGHS] I'm an American citizen.
成为绿卡持有者感觉如何？感觉就像梦想刚刚变成现实。我不知道是什么——感觉我不像个难民了。现在这不是那个躲避警察的难民了。 [笑] 我是美国公民了。
There was one thing about the approval of Abdi's visa that made us wonder. The day Abdi's visa was issued, before he heard the news, I had actually called the US embassy in Nairobi. I said I was a reporter doing a story about Abdi, and that I was curious about how long their decision would take because of my deadline. The woman I spoke to said she didn't know.
阿卜迪签证获批这件事有一点让我们感到好奇。在阿卜迪签证签发的当天，在他听到消息之前，我实际上打了电话给驻内罗毕的美国大使馆。我说我是记者，正在写关于阿卜迪的报道，我很好奇因为截止日期，他们的决定需要多长时间。那个接电话的女人说她不知道。
For nine days, Abdi hadn't heard anything. Two hours after my call, he got the good news. We asked the State Department if my phone call influenced their decision about Abdi's visa, and they told us, quote, "the journalist's call played no role in the timing of the visa issuance. Any visa process coinciding with a press inquiry is merely a coincidence."
有九天，阿卜迪没收到任何消息。在我电话打出两小时后，他收到了好消息。我们问国务院我的电话是否影响了他们关于阿卜迪签证的决定，他们对我们说，引用：“记者的电话在签证签发时机上没有发挥任何作用。任何签证程序与新闻咨询巧合仅仅是巧合。”
I can't prove anything, but that is at odds with what the woman on the phone told me back when I initially called the embassy. She said that now that they knew I was doing a story about Abdi, they would try and expedite the process, even though I told her that wasn't why I was calling, and that I was only asking for information.
我无法证明任何事情，但这与最初打给大使馆时接电话的女人告诉我的情况不符。她说，既然他们知道我正在做关于阿卜迪的报道，他们会尝试加快进度，尽管我告诉她那不是我打电话的原因，我只是要求信息。
We spoke with eight immigration lawyers, all experienced with the diversity visa lottery, and they all said my call probably bumped Abdi's application to the top of the pile that day. And with the lottery, because they give out a finite number of visas by a hard deadline, that can be the difference between making it to the US or not.
我们与八位移民律师交谈过，他们都有处理多元化签证抽奖的经验，他们都说我的电话可能那天把阿卜迪的申请顶到了堆栈的最顶端。而对于抽奖，因为他们要在严格的截止日期前签发有限数量的签证，这可能是能否去美国或不去的区别。
On August 11th, 2014, Hassan took Abdi to Nairobi airport. Abdi's now living in a small town in Maine. The woman who had been supporting him is putting him up with her family. About a month in, I give him a call.
2014年8月11日，哈桑带阿卜迪去了内罗毕机场。阿卜迪现在住在缅因州的一个小镇。那个一直在资助他的女人让他和她家人住在一起。大约一个月后，我给他打了个电话。
[PHONE RINGING]
[电话铃声]
Yes, Leo.
是的，利奥。
Hi, Abdi. How is it going? Good to hear from you.
嗨，阿卜迪。怎么样？很高兴听到你的消息。
It's going incredibly good. [LAUGHS] So can I tell you some of the surprises that strikes me most? There's a postbox. Do you know where the postbox is?
非常好。[笑] 那么我可以告诉你一些最让我震惊的惊喜吗？有个邮筒。你知道邮筒在哪里吗？
He's saying postbox. Mailbox.
他说邮筒。邮箱。
It's on the opposite side of the road, Leo. Can you believe that?
它在道路的对面，利奥。你能相信吗？
Abdi says he's expecting his social security card and green card in the mail.
阿卜迪说他正在期待他的社保卡和绿卡通过邮件寄来。
Are you telling me that everything will be delivered into that little box? Anybody can grab it?
你在告诉我所有东西都会送到那个小盒子里？任何人都能拿走？
The idea that a United States green card could sit in an unlocked mailbox on a public road blew his mind.
美国绿卡可以放在公共道路上未锁的邮箱里的想法让他震惊不已。
That was 10 months ago. Abdi spent the winter installing insulation on roofs around Maine. He really wants to apply for college, but it's hard because he sends a lot of his money back home. Hassan's now married, still in university, still living in Eastleigh.
那已经是10个月前了。阿卜迪在缅因州到处度过了一个安装屋顶隔热材料的冬天。他真的想申请大学，但这很难，因为他把很多钱寄回了家里。哈桑现在结婚了，还在上大学，仍然住在东利。
Abdi keeps in touch with the woman he was seeing back in Nairobi. She's still asking him to bring her to the US and marry her, but he's not sure he wants to do that. One time Abdi asked her straight up if she'd be into him if he didn't have a green card, and she was honest. She said no, which Abdi appreciated. He knows Somali women don't have a lot of options for leaving Eastleigh.
阿卜迪和他在内罗毕时交往的那个女人保持联系。她仍然请求他把她带到美国并和她结婚，但他不确定他想不想那么做。有一次阿卜迪直接问她，如果他没有绿卡，她是否会看上他，她很诚实。她说不会，阿卜迪对此表示赞赏。他知道索马里女性离开东利的选择并不多。
Part of me is still in Nairobi. It's still in Eastleigh. My brother's there, my friends are there.
我的一部分仍然在内罗毕。仍然在东利。我哥哥在那里，我的朋友们在那里。
Abdi says since he left his friends have this new ritual. When they go to the tea shop they all used to hang out at, which is just some tables and chairs a woman sets up on the street outside her building, they order an extra cup of tea for Abdi.
阿卜迪说，自从他离开后，他的朋友们有了一个新的仪式。当他们去他们常去的那个茶馆（那只是女人在她的楼外街上摆放的一些桌椅）时，他们会为阿卜迪多点一杯茶。
That's what they do. And they drink it for me. Like, if they are two or three people, they just take sips, sending me a photo of the tea and telling me, that's your tea. And then, the next picture, the tea is empty. And they're like, you just drank it. So I can feel that, you know? I'm right there.
他们就是这么做的。他们为我喝。就像，如果是两三个人，他们就喝一口，给我发一张茶的照片，告诉我，那是你的茶。然后，下一张照片，茶空了。他们说，你刚刚把它喝掉了。所以我能感觉到，你知道吗？我就在那里。
And then-- actually, it's sometimes amusing because I'm at the Dunkin' Donuts, drinking a coolatta, and my friend sends me a picture of the nice tea that we used to have at the tea shop, and then I send him a picture of the coolatta that I'm drinking.
而且——实际上，有时很有趣，因为我在邓肯甜甜圈店，喝着冷饮，我的朋友给我发一张我们过去在茶馆喝的那种好茶的照片，然后我给他发一张我正在喝的冷饮的照片。
So it's kind of like you guys are still going to the same tea shop. It's just, one of them is a Dunkin' Donuts in Maine.
所以这就好像你们还在去同一个茶馆。只是，其中一个是缅因州的邓肯甜甜圈店。
That's actually right.
确实是这样。
Sometimes, he says, the Kenyan police walk in and the next photo is an empty tea shop, empty chairs, half-full cups, everyone gone. Meanwhile, at the Dunkin' Donuts, sometimes cops walk in and say hi to him, or good morning. It's amazing, he says.
有时，他说，肯尼亚警察走进来，下一张照片就是空的茶馆，空的椅子，半杯茶，所有人都跑了。同时，在邓肯甜甜圈店，有时警察走进来跟他说嗨，或者早安。他说，这真是太奇妙了。
Leo Hornak with the BBC. It's been a year since we first ran this story. Abdi is still in Maine, working as an interpreter for the court system there, and doing some writing, an op-ed for the Washington Post , and he's working on a book.
BBC的利奥·霍纳克。我们第一次播出这个故事已经一年了。阿卜迪还在缅因州，做那里的法院系统口译员，并做一些写作，为《华盛顿邮报》写过专栏文章，他正在写一本书。
Our program was produced today by Brian Reed, with Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, Julie Snyder, and Nancy Updike. Editing help for today's show from Joel Lovell. Production help from Emmanuel Dzotsi. Our technical director is Matt Tierney.
我们的节目今天由布莱恩·里德制作，还有佐伊·蔡斯、肖恩·科尔、斯蒂芬妮·傅、查娜·乔菲-沃尔特、米基·米克、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普、朱莉·斯奈德和南希·厄普代克。今天节目的编辑协助来自乔尔·洛维尔。制作协助来自伊曼纽尔·佐齐。我们的技术总监是马特·蒂尔尼。
Thanks today to BBC radio current affairs. Hugh Levinson and Brigitte Harney at BBC'S Crossing Continents radio show, where a version of Leo's story first aired. Also to PRI's The World , where Leo is a producer. Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, The Public Radio Exchange.
今天感谢BBC电台时事部。休·莱文森和布丽吉特·哈尼来自BBC的《Crossing Continents》广播节目，利奥的故事版本最初就是在那里播出的。也感谢PRI的《The World》，利奥是那里的制作人。我们的网站是ThisAmericanLife.org。《This American Life》由PRX，公共广播交易所分发给公共广播电台。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he was giving me a ride home last night and I reached out to the radio which, of course, was playing our station and before I could even touch the tuner-- Torey is so hardcore Public Radio, he screeched the car over to the curb and he tells me--
一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，昨晚他载我回家，我伸手去够收音机，收音机当然正在播放我们的电台，在我还没碰到调谐器之前——托里是如此硬核的公共广播迷，他尖叫着把车停在路边，告诉我说——
Boy, step out of my car, or I'll call the police.
男孩，下车，否则我就报警。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week, with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周再见，会有更多《This American Life》的故事。